brian windhorst back here on the
richardson show how are you brian
i'm back in studio in la for the first
time in 14 months this week
i saw that i saw that that's one of the
reasons why that's one of the
reasons why i waited until a decent hour
to text you uh brian well
uh during the playoffs i'm up pretty
early unfortunately i bet
i bet why are the late uh the lost why
is los angeles basketball seasons
on the brink brian well different
reasons i mean the lakers are just
really banged up
and not only that but their team is
inadequately constructed to handle
the challenges in front of them which is
that
without anthony davis they really need
lebron to ramp up his scoring
and the way lebron does that is by
attacking the paint and either off the
dribble or getting in there
um out of you know with his back turned
and going to work
and number one i don't think he's
you know i don't think that ankle is
allowing him to do it i don't know if
he'll ever admit it but
you know if you look at his array of
moves that he's using in this series
it's not his normal array he hasn't gone
to a spin move and other stuff like that
i just don't believe he has the same
strength in there and then because the
lakers cannot buy an
outside shot um the and andre drummond
is you know guy who they're now playing
this the sun's past the paint you mean
you can see it as you watch this series
go along
sort of the resting position that the
suns take on defense in other words
whether
watching the ball they've gone from
being three or four steps outside the
paint uh
the other night um tuesday night their
players literally had a foot in the
paint when lebron was looking to
to go there and now all of a sudden
we're back to like 2007 lebron with
with those cavs teams where he had to be
superhuman to get it up onto the rim and
and so you know they're really their
only hope
you know that i see tonight is that some
of their guys start hitting some of
those outside shots and at least
you know get the points up or at least
force the suns to
rethink their strategy and i think it's
a big lift it could happen
i mean i've seen lebron do it dozens of
times but um
the suns are clearly in better shape and
we'll see if anthony can play
i think he's gonna you know try it uh i
don't know how effective he's gonna be
and then with the clippers rich um you
know they're uh
they're a very maddening team you know
last night luka doncic outplayed kawhi
leonard
that's just the truth of the matter and
um you know look
luca is potentially an all-time great uh
you know and and
kawhi has been really good in this
series i'm not saying that kawhi leonard
should be like
dragged because he got outplayed by a
guy who could be an mvp in the very near
future
but this is why losing games one and two
at home
is so damn hurtful because now you
have your star outplayed and you're on
the brink
because of the effort level and the
intensity level and the
and everything like that that they
brought out in the in those first two
games and
that's a penalty that they're now really
having to face
so let's take it one at a time then uh
lakers get eliminated tonight
um and what do you think the all their
their summer looks like going into
the fall what do they do what are the
moves that
that this team needs to make do you
think well rich you know dennis
schroeder turned down
a contract extension for a lot of money
uh in february
and um i wonder how he feels about that
because shooter has been awful
he's just been off frankly he hasn't
been the same player since he got
coveted
um and i mean i i don't mean maybe
he's feeling effects that you know jason
tatum talked about how it
was tugging on him for months that he
was having breathing issues for months
like you know schroeder
i mean you know and it's his personal
health situation so
you know he has every right to keep it
private and when schroeder has been
asked about
covet he's gotten very angry um he
doesn't want to talk about that's fine
but
i don't know what you want me to say he
got coveted he came back he's not been
the same player and frankly he's been
awful
in this series he was he was absolutely
dreadful
and he's their biggest free agent um
and the thing about it is it's it's
you know it's not a zero-sum thing it's
not like they can say okay dennis
you didn't work out for us thank you um
good luck to you now we're gonna go sign
kyle lowry it doesn't work that way
because the way it works in the nba is
you know you can't go over the salary
calf to sign players unless they're your
players on your team and if the lakers
lose tonight
and depending on how it goes i suspect
in the array
of stories that come out afterwards and
then the array of analysis
you're going to hear kyle lowry's name
discussed a lot because
the i mean ultimately the raptors didn't
trade him so it's
it's really hard to know like this would
have done it but you know
what we believe happened is that the
lakers were not willing to put taylor
horton tucker
into the trade in addition to dennis
schruter um
and could not get kyle lowry back and
because they want to protect their
young asset their young good player for
the future and you know horton tucker
has been at times in this series not
even gotten off the bench although he
did play well on tuesday and i expect
him to have a bigger role tonight
and so that's really the thing that
we're going to see you know um
you know is there something that you can
do with dennis schroeder or sign in
trading dennis shooter to improve him
horton tucker is also a free agent but
he's restricted and so they would have
control on keeping him but
that's going to be a real big thing one
of the things about when you have a
championship team sometimes it can be
tough to improve it
and you know their free agent signing
that they made um
their big creation fighting last year
was uh with montrez harrell who has
basically not been a factor in this
series so
you know i think there was a bunch of
things that are going to have to be
improved
what if the clippers get bounced is it
possible that kawhi
bounces himself what do you think
i just rich first off i don't i have not
heard anything about that and i'm just
going to go back
to when he was a free agent two years
ago right
we a lot of speculation but none of us
had a really good feel for what he was
going to do we thought there was a good
chance he was going to come to l.a and
we had felt the clippers for months but
we didn't know and and
i'm gonna say i'd have no insight i'm
not reporting anything
my feel is that everything he's gone
through to get here
i don't think he's walking on this team
um the challenge is
is does he sign a long extension or does
he keep it short does he sign another
short
a short deal and then what do they do
you know they
they are another team that has sort of
cast its whole lot and they may not have
a championship roster
and so you know to be honest with you to
pull the curtain back a little bit
um i know that this is going to probably
make you laugh but
this morning i have been reading stories
about
what steve ballmer did when he was ceo
of microsoft when he had major products
fail
but he did you know he they rolled out
the zune you know they were supposed to
beat the ipad or the iphone
the i pod and um they rolled out bing
remember bing you probably did ads for
ben
uh to try to beat google you know and it
didn't work out and you know um
he's worth 70 billion dollars because he
you know
really innovated at microsoft for a long
time and i kind of wanted to see
what he did did he fire everybody up
there or did you know i'm actually
researching that because i think it's
something that's going to be in his lap
and i think that there would be a change
but i'm not sure that
you know changing out you know the front
office not the whole front office but
making change in the front office is
going to change the
the menu that they've got on their plate
you know the team that they have is kind
of the team that they have
they thought it was a championship team
and if it isn't it's complicated
to to deal with that brian windhorst
here on the rich eisen show
uh what happened in boston best you can
tell brian
what happened with the celtics well
they had a very rough year this year um
they paid the tax uh of going deep into
the bubble all the teams who went deep
into the bubble
have had rough years this year you know
the heat are gone
the nuggets are okay but battered and
hanging on for dear life in that series
the celtics are gone
and the lakers are in serious trouble
being gone tonight um
they've had the virus problem so i mean
it's not in a vacuum
um on the on the broad scale on the
thirty thousand feet scale and the
reason that danny ainge has probably
said is probably um
leaving is because over the last two
plus years they've had a
massive and i can't underline this
enough a massive
talent drain from that organization from
from kyrie irving to al horford to
gordon hayward
all walking out the door for nothing um
they sign uh kemba walker and
unfortunately for him he ends up being
very injury prone
the draft picks that they held on to
rich you know for years you know all
these players would come to market
uh paul george kawhi leonard
anthony davis who didn't want to play
there um jimmy butler all these players
would come to market
and the celtics would make offers but
they wouldn't go all in for that player
and danny
became kind of famous for saying we were
so close we were so close
but they held on to those draft picks
that they had those extra picks and
they held on to tatum and brown because
they were like these guys are too
valuable
and those draft picks haven't panned out
they didn't turn out to be
top three picks like their earlier picks
that they had were they didn't
hit balls out of the park i mean they
drafted guys like
um romeo langford and aaron nee smith
and unless you're a celtics fan you
probably don't know who those players
are
they didn't hit home runs on that and so
it's been basically a massive talent
drain
and in these last two years as those
guys have walked on them
the nets have passed them the 76ers have
passed them
the bucks have passed them the hawks are
on a rocket ship
you know looking short-term future like
they
just are their short-term future you
know being an elite team doesn't look
great
and um i am stunned that that brad
stevens is taking over that job because
and this question was asked in the press
conferences yesterday to both brad
and to the owners why is why are the
celtics in better position with brad
stevens as
president versus brett stephens as coach
because it's one thing to take a roll
the dice on a guy who has no experience
to be your your president at some point
all people had no experience were given
the job but
with red auerbach i assume when he first
got the job there was a role that i saw
and that turned out okay
um but when you do that and also hurt
your coaching position
that's a that's a heck of a gamble and
they didn't give good answers for that
in my view
you know they gave a word salad so um to
me that's like one of the most important
things and the other thing is
when it comes to coaching you know you
know now the coaching hire is like
super duper duper duper vital he has
got to hit this coaching higher and if
he's going to hire a coach who has
experience
or is highly desirable that coach is
going to want to bring in his own people
so is brad gonna
take this promotion and then put his
foot on his entire coaching staff's
backside
and kick them out onto the street that's
not the brad stevens that i know
so he's going to have to be ruthless
right out of the gate so
i know that's the question i have about
how this coaching hire is going to be
you know is this going to be all all all
full bore or not
so then was this knee-jerk um
was this you know something that that
happened
over the weekend i mean honestly or was
this in the works
because from what you just told me it
doesn't sound
terribly well thought through right
i i'm assuming with all of that that
stevens would already have a coach
in mind to take his spot right i mean
wouldn't that be
part of the plan i would assume that as
well but i don't know that and you're
asking the second most important
question the most important question i
had yesterday was
why is this better for brad to be in the
front office instead of coaching
the second question is you know when did
this happen
you know did danny decide you know
because there had been some rumblings
within the league that danny may take a
step back either
to consultant or you know flat out you
know retiring
that i mean we were surprised at the
timing of it happening on this moment
but
that did not knock us over with a
feather those of us who work in the
league
the stevens move did now they have shown
in the past they can be very very covert
with brad stevens remember when they
hired him in this age where almost
everything the nba has reported we all
hear about it
and trust me a lot of moves that happen
that don't actually get publicly
reported
we've heard about it that stephen's
thing blew us out of the water when he
got
the coaching job and none of us knew
this was coming yesterday
and so and from what i understand rich
the other members of the front office
were caught off by that move not again
not that danny was leaving it was
the stevens was being promoted and his
coaching staff was unaware that it was
happening
and so the question i have is was this
something that you thought of six weeks
ago was it
something that you thought of six months
ago was it something you thought of six
days ago
when you had this when you made this
decision as a as an ownership group to
hand
you know to change your leadership for
the first time in 18 years and not have
a search
was it something that you sat and talked
with brad with for for days on end and
listened to all of his plans
or was it something you were just like
oh that sounds like a good idea i mean
these are all really important questions
that
you know they were not willing to give
the answers to and maybe that's smart
and maybe it's worrisome i don't know
well before i let you go brian windhorst
uh injury check here
uh embiid's knee and uh most uh i guess
uh uh pressing um chris paul's shoulder
what do you have for me
on those two big time name
players in the playoffs here i think uh
chris is going to be fine for tonight i
don't think that that
injury that he had the other night was
anywhere near as severe as what he had
in the series i think he should be fine
he'll have the same concerned about the
lingering stinger but i don't think that
new injury is a big issue from what i've
been told
and um you know in talk in talking to
the
to jack rivers and the 76ers players
last night doc was very non-committal
about um when embiid or if embiid would
come back um they you know they're not
ruling him out but
saying he's going to come back is i
don't know if i could say that's what
doc
said um you know this is a meniscus tear
uh he had a meniscus tear in his left
knee
a couple of years ago and needed surgery
now i am not an orthopedist
um i know that i definitely know that
not all meniscus tears are created equal
and i can't tell you the
difference between one versus the other
but most meniscus tears
require surgery and all of them require
significant rehab
um and i know they say it's small but
rich i mean i doubt there's such thing
as a small meniscus tear it may be small
in size but not small an impact
and in talking to the 76ers players
after last night's game
it certainly sounded like they were
preparing for the idea that he was going
to be out
for a while um he did like i said he did
shoot around before the game yesterday
you know kind of like in a
in like a message to the fans you know
i'm not i'm not done but this is a
i mean no matter how you spin it and
even if he's able to somehow get back
out on the court in this next series or
if they can
advance the conference finals rich it is
a a blow to them they were playing their
best basketball they won
10 out of 12 going into the to the end
of the regular season to clinch the
number one seed
they were so awesome in the first few
games of this series and b was averaging
30 points and shooting 67
he was hitting threes he was hitting
mid-rangers he was dominating in the
post
you know he was arguably the mvp of the
playoffs for the first three games i
know that that's not that meaningful but
i'm just telling you they were full bore
ahead doc is raving about his
conditioning
you know they you know they're not going
to have to play the bucks and the net
they're going to have to be one or the
other
they were looking like i could see their
lane to the finals and now their best
player is knocked down and
they're all putting a good face on it
and they're all referring to how during
the regular season that they went seven
and three when he missed 10 games and
that may be meaningful but i just cannot
see them beating the nets or the bucks
without embiid being at or near that mvp
level and maybe he'll surprise me and be
there but
it was a huge huge setback last
quick one uh and you do expect to have
uh see anthony davis tonight
you do expect to see him in game six i
don't expect it i i know i think he's
gonna work out before the game and
they're gonna take a look at him
but um remember it's not just the groin
he also sprained his left knee
and some people might argue and again
i'm not a physiotherapist but some
people might argue that
the left knee may have led to the groin
so you get worried about that kind of
stuff
but obviously it's a make or break game
so he's going to probably give it all he
can
you're the best brian thanks for taking
the call thanks for making the call
let's chat soon we'll see you on the
enjoy richard you got it that's brian
windhorst in studio on the jump
on espn hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here